c'est passé pour des faits oui pardon il
est déjà dans leurs parents oui mon
commissaire frichards de la dpa ressaisi
je vous appelle je suis bien au bar la
cession ou la non attends tenba oui oui
pardon je l'espère vraiment kiffé non
mais y'a pas qui c'est qui c'est qui
c'est monsieur et l'arrêt c'est pas ta
voix bizarre mais ça c'est une blague
bien sûr que tu fais une voix bizarre
mais voilà le plus normale possible qu'à
cardio cela regarde ça commence à monter
là alors on n'a pas si ça m'a aidé à
répétition n'appellent pas rater du
couscous hockey et on est dans le
personnage soit engagé le mec va à l'eau
oui le paradis du couscous à l'eau oui
oui mais non oui bonjour madame
commissaire preuve selon je vous appelle
parce qu'on a un petit doute là sur la
clientèle vous êtes
en observation la madame halo madame
madame c'est le commissaire bergame en
live tous les moyens soient tranquilles
je crois qu'on est tous les deux
spécialistes font c'est de fait partie
avec guardian annonce vient avec moi je
suis avec une amie ce que je dis qu'est
ce qu'on fait est ce qu'on va faire à
papa voilà a car avec mon groupe
allô allô oui à travel oui oui bonjour
désolé de vous déranger le commissaire
richard
je vous appelle concerne en rien à faire
le diabolo fraise et de trafic de
diabolo belle dans tout le
allô allô bonjour madame pardon excusez
moi
là on est un petit peu dans l'excitation
policière vous m'entendez la wii voilà
on a un petit problème d'art
il ya une personnes malfaisantes qui
doit ni dans votre restaurant qui c'est
qui doit être actuellement avec une
personne masculine est ce que c'est bien
le cas madame du monde exact je suis
d'accord est ce qu'il ya une personne
qui a un comportement étrange madame on
a repéré deux personnes qui sont en
fuite en est en observation madame
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner un
petit indice elle portait de veste en
tweed au fil des mois de travail oui
madame à l'eau nous aussi on travaille
madame s'il vous plaît madame oui c'est
c'est en fait c'est elie semoun à
l'appareil
vous êtes en direct sur s'est vite
oui bien sur la tête de ma mère sur la
tête de ma mère mais sur ces mythes
touche pas à mon pinceau en direct dès
21h10 aller mais je voulu rassurer la
douleur j'ai donné 3 millions c'est ça
c'est toi
madame vous croyez vraiment qu'un des
gens qui vous a pas le sachet jeu et
fois il arrive parfois que il ya des
gens qui meurent alors là c'est la femme
était déjà des gens qui sont faits
passer pour elie semoun et c'est la
nonna c'est d'arriver en cas d'enfant
alors à mon avis c'est qu'on a déjà
essayé de vous arrêter sur balladur ac
c'est quoi votre prénom
lily justine alors tu sais ce que ce
soit vous offrir un cadeau
oui qu'est ce que vous désirez en ce
moment avant noël et je sais que
derrière commandé un titre très sucré
vous plaisir
qu'est ce qui me ferait plaisir à aller
un iphone d'être smartphones 1 pourquoi
pas marc louis à l'essai pour moi c'est
cadeau
il ya aussi un maillot sur le dvd délice
les ménages sillage et achetez vous une
telle est d'abord d'accord et c'est
vraiment noah je viens de comprendre un
accord vous nous connaissez vous pouvez
nous décrire et laissez-vous de poils
d'écrire elle est comment je vous ai vu
à la télé il ya pas longtemps
c'était un cubain sur un kinder bueno
aires